welcome to the man of recaps this is
peaky blinders season six at the end of
season five tommy shelby was planning to
assassinate the english fascist oswald
mosley but somehow the plan leaked and a
bunch of tommy's men got killed so tommy
who's not used to losing was in a bad
headspace he's also been hallucinating
his dead wife grace and we left off on a
cliffhanger as tommy was thinking of
shooting himself and he does pull the
trigger but the gun wasn't loaded his
family thought he might try something
like that and took the bullets out so
tommy shelby's not done yet he's gotta
keep fighting now it wasn't mostly who
found out about tommy's plan so who was
it well now we learn it's the good old
irish republican army it wasn't about
you tommy we just want mosley live for
our own reasons but it's now very
personal because one of the people they
killed is aunt paulie no
her son tommy's cousin michael who was
already set up for a war with tommy now
blames tommy for his mother's death for
some reason and hates him even more and
now it's a four-year time jump it's the
last day of american alcohol prohibition
tommy shelby's actually stopped drinking
he's trying to keep a clear head and be
a better person these days though he
still gets violent when he has to he's
meeting cousin michael here who's grown
out a stupid mustache he's been in
america working for the crime boss of
boston or his wife gina's uncle jack a
big part of their business has been
bootlegging alcohol but now that it's
legal it's like hey how about opium
tommy wants to sell them his massive
stockpile in one big deal and get out of
the game michael's playing nice for now
but secretly he still plans to kill
tommy but tommy also knows that he calls
the cops on michael with the pack of
opium and gets him in jail so he's
sidelined for the season so now coming
to england to meet with tommy directly
is the big boss uncle jack nelson he's
basically an american tommy shelby rose
from nothing to the crime boss of boston
and has now gone legit as a big
political player and he's like yeah man
we can do this drug deal but what i
really want is for you to hook me up
with english fascists and tommy's got
that covered he's still pretending to be
friends with oswald mosley who's all
excited about his new girlfriend but
it's all confusing because tommy's
officially in parliament as a socialist
but oswald thinks he's secretly a
fascist who's gonna turn when the time's
right but tommy's really working for
winston churchill to infiltrate the
fascists and undermine them but all
that's on hold for a bit when tommy's
daughter ruby gets sick with
tuberculosis but tommy doesn't trust
modern medicine he thinks it's probably
a romani curse he goes to see his dead
brother john's widow esme who does have
some info for him remember the cursed
sapphire that killed grace tommy didn't
destroy it he gave it away and then that
woman gave it to her daughter who died
and so now she cursed tommy's daughter
and there's no time to lift the curse
his daughter ruby dies this shakes tommy
to his core and he vows he's gonna be a
better person in her honor but the first
thing he does is track down the poor old
woman who accidentally cursed him and
kills her not the best start tommy now
how's the rest of the shelby family
doing well arthur's worse off than ever
he's super addicted to opium their
sister aydah's trying to take care of
him and also run the business while
tommy's running around tommy tries to
help his brother get clean in fact he
brings in his ex-wife linda they don't
get back together but she helps him pray
the younger brother finn is still
hanging around in the background tommy's
wife lizzy by the way is also in this
season but turns out there's another
shelby running around tommy's son he
didn't know about from a one-night stand
20 years ago he goes by duke and tommy
brings him into the family because he
just got some bad news from his doctor
he's got an inoperable brain tumor and
has about one year left to live so tommy
accelerates his plans brings all his
fascist friends together who by the way
are just all sleeping with each other so
they make their plans for a new world
order with the fascist america a fascist
england and ira girls here for a fascist
ireland and tommy's pretending to be
fully on board although of course he's
planning to betray them but naturally
they're planning to betray him too
michael gets the okay to kill tommy at
the drug deal now arthur's supervising
finn and this other guy who are in
charge of fixing football matches but
when a referee won't take the money they
gotta kill him and duke doesn't want any
part of that he's like yo pops i'm a
thief not a killer let me just work with
the horses but now jack nelson goes to
this guy and gets him to betray the
shelbys which actually he already did
he's the one who blabbed last season
about the mostly assassination but tommy
finds out so invites him to a party but
it's not a party it's an execution it's
like yo finn we know he's your friend
you gotta kill him to prove your loyalty
but finn tries to shoot duke instead but
oh there's no bullets in the gun it was
a test and finna failed so duke shoots
this guy in the head even though five
minutes ago he didn't want to kill
people and now he's an official shelby
while finn is kicked out of the family
meanwhile the ira come to assassinate
arthur but they also knew about that and
he gets to jump on him but somehow this
turns into a 30 minute long can't see
anything boring gunfight but in the end
arthur kills her gets revenge for aunt
paulie so now we're back in canada for
the fake drug deal where they're gonna
plant a bomb in tommy's car and so is
this how thomas shelby meets his end
boom
nope he's fine it was the other car that
blew up tommy saw this one coming and
had johnny dogs switch it out he says
goodbye to cousin michael i'm not mad
i'm just disappointed and turns out the
drug deal's still on tommy made a secret
deal with his old friend alfie solomons
yes he's moved to boston and is leading
the jewish gang over there he's more
than happy to see jack nelson weekend
and take this opium off tommy's hands
and so once again tommy shelby comes out
on top he blows up his house just to be
cool he is still dying though so he
holds a big family dinner to say
farewell he doesn't tell them he's dying
but it's pretty obvious so he sets off
to enjoy his final days in solitude and
go out on his own terms and it looks
like this is it the end of tommy shelby
but he has a quick hallucination with
his daughter ruby who points out the
newspaper with oswald mosley's wedding
photo has his doctor in it tommy pays
this guy a visit and learns that yeah he
doesn't actually have a brain tumor
mosley faked it all to you know get
tommy out of the picture so tommy
shelby's got a new lease on life ready
to finish what he started and take down
his biggest rival oswald mosley and
while this is the final season the
chances of a peaky blinders movie to tie
it all up seems likelier than ever and
that's where peaky blinders season 6
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]